Hi. So this lecture is
going to discuss skin signs
of systemic disease.
And what does that mean?
If a patient has some type
of systemic condition,
sometimes dermatologists
are actually able
to make a diagnosis
of their condition
just by the skin signs
that they show. So
we are going to be
discussing this today.
So let's start off with
cutaneous rheumatology. There
are a number of systemic
diseases that can affect
the skin, hair, and nails,
and many are autoimmune
with tissue destruction
in numerous organ systems.
And important to note,
there are characteristic
changes of the connective
tissue, which will aid in the
diagnosis of systemic
conditions. And the diagnostic
criteria of each disease
is not only based on the
history, but also you have
to do a physical exam and
medical testing, such as
biopsies and blood work.
So what is this? What
do you see here? Now,
remember the other lecture
I showed you suboreak
dermatitis affects the
nasolabial folds, correct?
Well, look at this rash.
This is a butterfly rash.
You have this extending
over here, and this is a
butterfly rash. So this type
of rash is seen in systemic
lupus erythematosus. So
a patient may not know
that they have systemic
lupus erythematosus, but you
as a dermatologist can
see, oh, the patient has a
butterfly rash. Maybe they
have other things that would
warrant that diagnosis.
Okay, and then what do
you see here? You see erythematous
papules with scarring.
So this leads me to
believe that maybe the
patient has discoid lupus.
And the only way to really
know is by doing a biopsy.
And we would biopsy this.
So what is systemic
lupus erythematosus?
It's classified
by three different
things, acute,
subacute, and chronic.
The chronic only affects
the skin. It can be anywhere
from benign to systemic.
The acute one is practically
always associated with
systemic lupus, and
it's highly photosensitive,
whereas the subacute type
has more of a rash, such as
an annular or papulosquamous
rash. And then the chronic
type really affects
the skin, and you can see
it's either hypertrophic
Or you can get lupus
paniculitis, which is a little
bit deeper, discoid
lesions, and discoid lesions
in the mouth. And we're
going to review all that.
So lupus erythematosus,
it's a multi
-system autoimmune
disorder involving the
connective tissue
and blood vessels.
Now there are 11, there's
11 criteria for lupus.
And how do you make the
diagnosis? you need four of
these 11 criteria to make
the diagnosis. The first
thing you have to have is
a butterfly rash, which is
this erythematous rash
sparing the nasolabial folds
in a butterfly distribution.
You need to have a discoid
rash, which are erythematous
papules with scarring,
and it occurs with chronic
lesions. You can have
arthritis or pain in two or
more joints. You can have
sericitis or fluid around
the heart and lung. You
can have blood work
abnormalities such as anemia,
leukemia, thrombocytopenia.
You can have oral ulcers,
kidney disease or
protein in the urine.
You can have photosensitivity,
a positive ANA. And this
positive ANA is actually
positive in 95% of
patients. You can have
autoantibodies, and you can
have neurological disorders,
such as seizures or
psychosis. So you don't
have to have all of these.
You only need four of
these 11 to make the
diagnosis of systemic lupus.
So what are the autoantibodies
in lupus? You have anti
-double stranded DNA, and
that can indicate kidney and
skin disease. You can have
anti-Smith antibodies, which
can indicate kidney disease.
You can have anti-Rho
and anti-law antibodies,
which can indicate skin and
kidney disease and fetal heart
problems. And let's say a
patient is on these medications,
any of these medications,
and then they have a rash
and the rash looks like
lupus. You can have a drug
-induced lupus. And if you
do an anti-histone antibody,
that's more indicative of
a drug-induced lupus. And
then if a patient is pregnant
and then they lose their
pregnant, they lose their
baby, and this happens a
couple of times, you always
want to do antiphospholipid
antibodies because this can
indicate that the patient
has some autoimmune issues.
Subacute lupus is the
next classification,
and you can get this
annular or psoriasiform
areas of the skin. And
50% of these patients
develop four or more
criteria for SLE.
60 to 80% of these
patients have a
positive ANA, and
anti-rheal antibodies
are positive in 80
% of these cases.
Moving on to chronic cutaneous,
and as dermatologists,
this is what we see
more often. You have the
hypertrophic or thickened
areas of the skin, and
sometimes it can look
farrucus or warty looking.
and then you have the
discoid lupus erythematosus
where you see this erythematous
scaly plaque and then
what happens is it looks
a little scarred and you
lift up the top layer you
lift up the plaque a little
bit and underneath you see
this carpet tack you see
these little carpet tacks
underneath the scale of
this of the discoid lupus
and then what happens is
in the scalp you can get
alopecia and alopecia is hair
loss and what happens is
this discoid lesions cause
so much scarring it cause
follicular plugging so
you get you know you don't
see the hair follicles
here right here you might see
a few of the hair follicles
here you don't see any
hair follicles and it
causes scarring of the scalp
called scarring alopecia
here you see the discoid
type where there's atrophy
in the center and here you
see oral discoid lupus.
So how do you evaluate
and treat these
patients? History is so
important. You ask the
patient, do they go
outside in the sun and do
they get red and like
a really bad sunburn?
What's their physical
exam? Do they have
any rashes that, you
know, they can show
you that would lead
to this diagnosis.
We do blood work. We do a
CBC. We do autoantibodies.
We do a urinalysis. Is there
protein in the urine? So
all these things, history
is so important and also
trying to figure out why this
patient has maybe protein
in the urine or anemia
or things like that. That
can better help you make
the diagnosis. But the most
important is a biopsy of
lesional skin because that's
positive in 90% of patients
with lupus. So you take
one of those lesions that
they have, you do a biopsy,
and that can confirm that
diagnosis. You can also
biopsy non-lesional skin,
non-sun exposed skin, and
that's called the lupus band
test. And this is another
test for lupus. And how do
you treat these patients?
Sunscreens, right?
Because the patient has
photosensitivity. You want
to protect them from the sun.
Topical and systemic
steroids and anti-malarials
or immunosuppressants.
Now talking about anti
-malarials, there's
hydroxychloroquine. If you
can all remember during
COVID, there was a big
hype about hydroxychloroquine
treating COVID.
And then some of
these lupus patients,
you know, sometimes I
have some lupus patients
that were on this
medication, sometimes it
was difficult to get
because everybody else was
trying to order
hydroxychloroquine for COVID.
The next autoimmune condition
is dermatomyositis. This
is an autoimmune disease
targeting the skin and the
muscle. Now, you need two
out of these four criteria
or findings to get the
diagnosis plus a cutaneous
finding. And that will give
you probable cause that this
is dermatomyositis. So
what are the four findings?
You have proximal symmetrical
muscle weakness, and that
involves the trunk and
shoulders and the neck. You
can have elevated muscle
enzymes, and the most common
is the CPK. You can
have an abnormal EMG or
electromyelogram, which
shows electrical
activity in the muscle.
And you can have an abnormal
muscle biopsy. If you
have two of these four
plus one of the cutaneous,
then you have probable
cause that this patient has
dermatomyositis. Now, what
are the cutaneous conditions?
You can have a heliotrope
rash. You can have gotron's
papules. Now, the
heliotrope rash is swelling,
violicious swelling
around the eyes. Gotron's
papules are erythematous
papules on the knuckles.
these two are pathognomonic
for having this
condition and remember
what pathognomonic is it
means if you have heliotrope
rash or gotranspapules
you're most likely to
have dermatomyositis.
Other cutaneous findings
include periungal
telangiectasias which are
around the nail periungal is
nail telangiectasias or
blood vessels. You can have
poikoloderma which is
hyper, hypo, pigmentation,
erythema, telangiectasias. I'll
show you a picture of that.
Malar erythema or
redness around the malar
area of the face and
photosensitivity.
And what causes
dermatomyositis?
Drugs, infections,
trauma, vaccination,
malignancy, pregnancy,
abnormal circulating anti
-G1 antibodies. Any of
these things can cause
dermatomyositis. Here
you see the swelling,
violaceous rash around the
eyelids. That is called
the heliotrope rash.
And here you see these Gotruns
papules over the
bony prominences.
See these papules?
Erythematous scaly papules.
Here you see around the
nails telangiectasia
and cuticular of the
cuticles hypertrophy
thickened. That's
what you see in here.
And then poicoloderma
is, you have
telangiectasias, which
you can see over here,
pigmentation,
erythema,
just kind of all different
colors of the skin.
And a lot of times
sun exposure can cause
this poicoloderma as
well as dermatomyositis.
So what are the
systemic manifestations?
Patients can have
stiffness of the joints.
They can have
difficulty swallowing.
They can have problems
with breathing and lung
disease, and that's more
associated with anti
-Joborant antibodies. They
can have heart disease.
And then they can have
a malignancy, and the
most common one is
ovarian cancer in females.
How do you evaluate and
treat this condition?
Well, you want
to get a history.
Does the patient
have any malignancy
or any infections,
or is the patient on
any medications
that can cause this?
So you want to actually,
if the patient does
end up having this, you
want to investigate to
see if they have any
underlying malignancies.
So you want to do in
women a pap smear and a
mammogram. You want to
make sure they've had a
****** exam and a
colonoscopy. You want to do a
chest x-ray to see if
there's anything in the
lungs. You want to test
their stool for blood.
And this will all test
for malignancies. You
also want to evaluate
their muscle. if they have
any muscle disease, a
muscle biopsy and an EMG.
You want to do a
pulmonary function test to
see if they have any lung
conditions, lung disease,
or esophageal studies
for muscle weakness.
And then as far as blood
work, you want to get
the CPK because that's the
most specific for muscle
disease. And you want to
do anti-G1 antibodies.
disease. The next autoimmune
condition is called
scleroderma. This is
sclerosis or stiffening of the
skin. It's autoimmune
disease and what happens is
fibroblasts overproduce
collagen causing fibrosis
and stiffening of the
skin. You can also have
sclerotic changes not only
of the skin but also internal
organs such as the lungs,
heart, and GI tract,
and there are two categories
of scleroderma. There's
the localized scleroderma
called morphia, and
then you have the systemic
scleroderma, which is
limited, either crest or
acrosclerosis, or progressive,
which involves multi
-systems and multi-organs.
So the localized type of
scleroderma called morphia,
here you get these
violaceous to ivory colored
hardened skin with possible
depression underneath.
It may be solitary, it
may be generalized, it may
be linear. You have something
called encudé sabre,
which is linear morphia
of the head. It's not
that common. And then you
have pansclerotic, which
not only involves the skin,
but anything underlying
the skin, such as the
fat, muscle, and bone.
So here you see the solitary
plaque of scleroderma
or morphia.
Here it's more generalized,
but you do have solitary
plaques, but you see this
hardening and it looks
depressed, right? And
you see one here and you
see one here. This is
generalized morphia. And the
pansclerotic type affects
not only the skin, but
under the skin, the dermis,
fat, muscle, and bone.
Here you have the linear
type extending like this,
linear morphia, and
here you have encu de
saber, which almost
looks like the strike of
a sword, and this is
the patient's forehead.
Moving on to systemic
scleroderma, you have the
limited type. The first
one is acrosclerosis, which
is limited to the hands,
feet, face, and arms.
And you see the skin,
how kind of tight it
looks. Sometimes you lose
the lines of the skin,
but it's very, very
tight and stiff looking.
And the next limited
type is crest.
This is a mnemonic for crest.
Calcinosis cutis, calcium
deposits in the skin.
Raynard's phenomenon. What
is Raynard's phenomena,
it's when you go out into
the cold and your hands get
very cold and stiff. That
could be a sign of scleroderma.
You have esophageal
dysfunction, hard to swallow,
sclerodactyly,
tight, tapered skin of
the fingers and toes,
and telangiectasias
of the hands and face.
Here's telangiectasias.
They're blood
vessels of the skin.
Here's an example
of calcium deposits
of the skin.
And then you have the
systemic type of scleroderma
or the progressive type,
and that can affect not
only the skin, but also
internal organs. So it can
affect the lungs called
pulmonary fibrosis. It can
affect the kidneys. It can
affect the heart. And with
the skin, you get this
mask-like faces. You lose
the facial lines. The skin
looks very, very tight.
How do you make the diagnosis?
You do an ANA, because an
ANA can also be positive
in scleroderma. You get
an anti-SCL70 antibody,
you can get an anti
-centromere antibody, and all
of these antibodies can
lead to the diagnosis.
You need to test
for underlying skin
conditions and internal
organs, and the
treatment is steroids
and immunosuppressants.
Moving on to sarcoidosis,
this is a granulomatous
disease more common in
African-American patients.
It primarily affects the
lungs by causing bilateral
hyalur lymphadenopathy.
And with the skin, you get
these granulomatous lesions
called lupus perneo.
And what happens with
lupus perneo, you take
the skin lesion on the
patient, you take a glass
slide, You press the
glass slide on the skin
lesion, and this causes
an apple jelly color.
And this is dioscopy
positive. It's a test to
see that this patient
can have sarcoidosis.
Another lesion of
sarcoidosis is erythema
nodosum. And this
is a nonspecific
lesion, but it has a
really good prognosis.
So the lesion, if you do
a biopsy, it's not going
to show sarcoidosis. It's
going to show erythema
nodosum. And there are
other causes of erythema
nodosum. However,
sarcoidosis is one of them.
So besides the granulomas
that you get with sarcoidosis,
if you do blood work, you
can get a hypercalcemia
or elevated calcium
levels, and you can get an
elevated ACE enzyme,
angiotensin converting enzyme.
So here you have these
granulomatous lesions over
here. This patient has
lupus perneo, and you see
this lesion of lupus
perneo, you take this glass
slide, you put it on top,
and it has this apple
jelly appearance, so this
is dioscopy positive.
And here's an example of
erythema nodosum. You see
these kind of faint pink
hyperpigmented nodules on the
legs, very common on the
legs. It's nonspecific, but
patients that end up having
this can have sarcoidosis,
but patients that have this
have the best prognosis.
Bichette's disease,
this is recurrent oral
aphthous ulcers. You need
two of the following to
call it Bichette's,
******* aphthous ulcers,
uveitis or inflammation
in the uvea, arthritis,
skin lesions called cutaneous
pustular vasculitis,
which on the skin,
you get these pustules
that look like vasculitis,
and you can get
meningoencephalitis.
Now, one way to make the
diagnosis of this is pathology,
where you get a pustule,
and after you puncture
the skin by a needle, let's
say, you get this inflammatory
pustule, and that's
called the pathology test.
So here you have oral
aphthous ulcers. Here is
*******, and here is uveitis,
inflammation of the uvea.
Kawasaki's disease or
mucocutaneous lymph
node syndrome, you need
five out of this six
criteria. So here you
see crash and burn.
These are the criteria
that you use. You need five
or six out of them. And the
first one is conjunctival
injection where you see
this patient's eyes are
injected. It's very, very
red. The rash, you get an
erythematous rash spreading
from the palms and soles
to the trunk. You have
adenopathy or lymph node mass
greater than 1.5 centimeters.
You can have what's
called a strawberry tongue,
looks like strawberry.
You can get a rash around
the hands and feet and
desquamation of the digit. you
see here that the skin is kind
of peeling off, that's
desquamation. And then you
get unexplained fever greater
than five days. So you need
five out of the six of
these criteria. It affects
children less than 10 years,
and there's a 2% mortality.
So the next eight slides,
this is for you to do
on your own leisure, if
you're so interested.
My resident, my past
actually students put
this together because
they were very interested
in dermatology. And
what you do is read the
case, what's your
differential diagnosis and
what labs and diagnostic
tests would you perform
to narrow down your
differential diagnosis.
For example, if you read
the case, the patient is
likely to have dermatomyositis
due to any of these
things that the patient
may have. or the patient is
unlikely to have SLE due to
their muscle findings. So
I will let you review these
cases, and there's eight
slides of these. So I'm
just going to quickly go
through these, and you can
do these at your leisure.
Okay,
next is human graft versus
host disease. Here you have
an immunocompetent donor
with an immuno-incompetent
recipient, okay? So what
does that mean? The organ is
rejected by the host. There
is histo-incompatibility.
And there are different
types of graft-versus-hosts
depending on how many days
post-bone marrow transplant.
The acute is 14 to
100 days, and the
chronic is greater
than 100 days.
so acute graft versus host
14 day to 100 days postbound
marrow transplant can
affect the skin liver and
GI tract and here you have
this classic maculopapular
rash now this is a little
bit worse here you maybe
the patient started off
with a maculopapular rash
and then the patient formed
blisters this is toxic
epidermal necrolysis and
this is a life-threatening
condition the patient has
to be hospitalized for this.
Chronic graft versus
host. This is over 100
days after bone marrow
transplant. This can
affect many organs.
And with the skin, you
get skin sclerosis or
stiffening of the skin,
almost looking like
scleroderma, correct?
Cutaneous disease and GI
abnormalities of the stomach.
you have hereditary
hemorrhagic telangiectasia.
This is a genetic condition
where you get telangiectasias
or blood vessels of
the mouth and GI tract.
And it's an early sign.
An early sign of this
is epistaxis or bleeding
of the nose. And you could
also get bleeding of the
bowel called melanoma.
So here you have
pinpoint bleeding
around the lips,
as you see here.
so what is the diagnostic
criteria for this condition
spontaneous nosebleeds
multiple telangiectasias
around the lips you can
have visceral involvement
including the gi tract
and it can be it's genetic
gardner syndrome this
is a condition where the
patient has colorectal
polyposis that does
have malignant potential.
So the polyps can be
malignant. What else
can the patient have?
Multiple cysts on the
face, osteomas, which are
bony abnormalities, and
dental abnormalities.
So here you have a
patient that has Gardner
syndrome. They have
multiple epidermoid cysts.
You see a cyst here,
most common on the face.
Here you see osteomas
or abnormalities
in the bone, most
common around the jaw.
And here you have
dental abnormalities.
Look at these two
rows of teeth.
Very interesting.
Now, the next couple of
patients have non-malignant
polyposis syndromes. Now,
what can happen with these
conditions, these can be
related to cancers, but the
polyps that they have in the
GI tract are not malignant.
So here you have Putz
-Jager, which is genetic.
You can have GI polyps
that are not malignant.
You can also get spotty
melanin pigmentation,
but you do have a risk
of GI and non-GI cancer.
So here you have this
spotty, you see these little
spotty pigmentation over
here and over here and
over here. And it's mostly
found around the lips.
And the patient also has
non-malignant GI polyps.
Cowden syndrome, also genetic.
And the patient has GI polyps
that are not malignant.
They have warty papules
of the face. However,
they do have an increased
malignancy in general
of breast cancer, but not
the polyps themselves.
so here you see warty
polyps warty papules of the
face this is cowden syndrome
non-malignant GI polyps
and warty papules acrochordons
this you should really
pay attention to because
everybody has these they
are so common they're
around the neck the armpit
the groin they are associated,
they can be, not they
are, they can be associated
with colonic polyps, but
most times they're not.
And what they are, are just
outgrowths of normal skin
in sites of friction. So
I see this a lot in patients
under the armpits, the
neck, in the groin, and
patients just don't like
these. It's a cosmetic
nuisance. And they do increase
with age. Usually younger
patients don't have these,
although they can, but
usually as you get older,
you can get these. And they're
more or less associated
or can be associated with
obesity and diabetes.
And the way to, this is
on the axilla and this is
on the neck. The way to
remove them is we inject a
little numbing medicine
and we just snip them off.
Skin signs associated with
certain liver conditions,
cirrhosis of the
liver. So in In these
patients, patients
frequently develop spider
telangiectasias or angiomas.
They look like little
spiders. That's why
they're called that.
Patients can also have
itching of the skin,
palma erythema,
which is redness of
the palms, and nail
changes called Terry's
nails. I will show
you a picture.
So here you see this
central arteriole.
And then what
happens is you have
almost like the
legs of the spider.
So this is called
spider angioma.
And this is more common on
the face, on the trunk in
patients with cirrhosis of
the liver. But honestly,
I have patients that have
this and they don't have
cirrhosis. I'm talking about
when patients have many
of these, that's more
indicative of the cirrhosis.
So here you see
spider angiomas,
the little central arterial,
and then the kind of legs.
and here it is on the chest.
And Terry's nails,
if you look at your
nails, your nails
are normally all
pink, correct?
Except for down here.
Well, look, the white
of, now the white of the
nail is actually almost
the whole nail. So the
proximal two-thirds of the
nail appears white, and
this is a nonspecific
condition for liver disease.
pancreatic cancer and skin
disease so here you have
systemary joseph nodule
what is this this is a
malignant metastatic nodule
near the umbilical area
and it may be the first
sign of pancreatic cancer
so this really does have
a very very poor prognosis
skin signs of certain
cardiovascular conditions
the first one is relapsing
polychondritis this is
recurrent inflammation
affecting the cartilage and
what happens is the patient
can have tender erythematous
swollen ear and i'll
show you a picture of
this so this is the ear
it's recurrent inflammation
so you see redness here
but look at the ear here,
it's very, very swollen. So
this recurrent inflammation
of the college can be a
sign of heart disease.
And it may occur in
patients with heart aortic
insufficiency and patients
with aortic aneurysms.
Skin signs of certain
kidney conditions.
So chronic renal
failure related skin
findings. Now, if a
patient is on dialysis
because they have
kidney failure,
what can the skin signs
be? You can have anemia.
You can have generalized
hyperpigmentation.
You can have xerosis or dry
skin. You can have itchy
skin. You can get something
called uremic frost.
What is uremic frost?
This is urea crystals that
form because the waste
products can't be excreted
because the patient has
kidney failure and cannot
excrete. So that's why
you get this uremic frost.
These patients can
have metastatic
calcification in the
skin and the patients
can also have Bullis
disease of dialysis.
So here you see Bullis
And here you see the
uremic frost I was talking
about. These patients
have kidney failure.
They cannot excrete. So
they have these toxins
that build up on their
skin called uremic
frost. You see here this
white area on the skin?
Almost looks like a frost.
Okay, skin signs
of malnutrition
and vitamin deficiencies.
So the first is kwashiorkor
protein malnutrition.
What do you see in
these patients? You see
peripheral pitting edema.
You can see enamel pain,
dermatosis, and
something called the flag
sign, which are depigmented
bands in the hair.
You can see a
distended abdomen,
moon faces, which is
rounded prominence
of the cheeks, muscle atrophy.
And here you see this
peripheral pitting edema. When
it's mild, it only involves
the feet. But as it progresses,
it can involve not only
the feet, the legs, and the
upper arms. And when
it's severe, it can cause
generalized edema and a distended
abdomen, as you see here.
This is enamel paint
dermatosis. Here you have
thin, dry, peeling
skin with areas of
hyperkeratosis, which is
thickening of the skin
over here, and
hyperpigmentation. It looks like
enamel paint. That's
why they call it that.
And then the
flaxcine. The flaxcine
are depigmented
bands in the hair.
And what happens? Well,
when the patient has
adequate dietary intake,
there's normal hair. When the
patient has inadequate
dietary intake, there's
this not normal band of
hair. So intermittent periods
of adequate dietary
intake restores hair color
and results in alternating
bands of normally
colored when there's adequate
intake and abnormally
discolored when there's
inadequate intake,
dietary intake.
Aquedermis enteropathica,
this is a deficiency of zinc
due to malabsorption. There's
a defect in intestinal
zinc absorption, and it
mostly occurs in infants.
And common findings include
alopecia or hair loss,
diarrhea,
severe growth retardation,
frequent infections,
and I'll show
you the skin signs in a minute.
The treatment is zinc.
And here are the skin
signs. So this patient
has vesicular bolus and
erythematous rashes.
These are kind of look like
blisters and erythematous
rashes. and it's most commonly
in the acral, perioral
area, perirectal area are
the most common areas.
What does this look like?
This looks like a little
eczema, right? But
when you test for zinc,
then you know that there's
a deficiency in zinc.
Here you have it again,
perioral, perioral, perirectal.
Dermatitis repetiformis,
this is a gluten
-sensitive enteropathy.
Patients are
insensitive to gluten, and
this causes a cutaneous
eruption. And the cutaneous
eruption is dermatitis
repetiformis, which are
little erythematous, crusted
papules, very, very, very
severely itchy, mostly
on the extensor areas or
the elbows and the knees.
And you could do
autoantibodies to make the
determination, but most
commonly we do a skin biopsy.
So it's a pruritic inflammatory
rash that have group vesicles,
papules and vesicles
on the elbows,
knees are the most common
areas, the extensor areas,
even the lower buttocks
and the scalp. and how
do we treat these patients
with a gluten-free diet
dapsone is a medication
that we can use as well so
here you see these erythematous
crusted scaly papules
on the elbows and here
you see it on the knees
again here and then
the buttock area
niacin niacin deficiency
we have the three d's
dermatitis which is a
rash diarrhea and dementia
so here you have the dermatitis
and sun exposed areas
erythematous almost a
little violaceous patches on
the sun exposed areas of the
skin and you have something
called casal's necklace
where you have this what
looks like a necklace and
then around the neck and
that's the dermatitis of
pellagra and here you see it
again the dermatitis or
casal's necklace of pellagra
scurvy this is
vitamin c deficiency
where you see follicular
hyperkeratotic
papules and what
does that mean?
They're papules around the
hair follicles and they're
thickened. And you can also
see corkscrew hair. So the
hair that's coming out of here
may look like a corkscrew.
That's why they call
them corkscrew hairs. You
can have swollen gums. You
can have slow wound healing,
edema of the legs,
and it can also
cause nosebleeds and
blood in the urine.
Here you see the follicular
hyperkeratotic papules
as you see here and
these are reddish bluish
bruise-like papules
surrounding hair follicles.
Now what this slide is it's
basically mnemonics for
all the things that we just
discussed in this presentation
so this is for you to
review this slide and maybe
you'll be able to remember
things a little bit better.
That concludes this lecture.